PROFESSOR: Any questions before
I obliterate all this
lovely geometry?
No.
OK.
We handled them during
intermission I guess.
Let me do a couple more plane
groups just very quickly to
show you how they come out
without going through all of
the steps, because I think we've
seen now what one has to
do to derive these.
There are two that are left.
One is a threefold axis, and
if that's all the symmetry
we've put into the lattice,
we're combining a threefold
rotation axis with a primitive
lattice, and we know that this
has to be hexagonal net.
Because from our depth of
experience, we know that is
the shape of a lattice that is
demanded by a threefold axis.
It has two translations, T1,
that are identical in length.
And this angle between them
is exactly 120 degrees.
That's what we saw a threefold
access require.
So now what we are doing is
putting in a threefold axis at
one lattice point, and this
means we are adding the
operations A 2 pi over 3.
A minus 2 pi over 3.
I'll choose to define a 120
degree rotation that way, and
the operation A 2 pi, which is
the identity operations.
So I'm adding three
operations.
Putting the threefold axis in
at all these locations.
They will all be translationally
equivalent.
The pattern of this particular
plane group is going to be the
pattern of a threefold axis.
And so there will be one motif
here, 120 degrees away.
There will be a--
sorry to wipe out those
operations--
120 degrees.
There'll be another object
located here.
And 120 degrees again,
there will be another
object located here.
So these guys will fall
at the corner of
an equilateral triangle.
And the same will be at the
other corners of the net, and
that, as I've said before,
is the pattern
of that plane group.
And that's a plane group
that we would call P3.
Primitive lattice that has to
be hexagonal, and what we've
added to it is a
threefold axis.
OK, let me down here just
indicate the combinations that
we would do.
And I could do it up on top,
but I can work with this
translation as well, which is
easier to reach at this late
hour in the afternoon.
Let me combine A 2 pi over 3
with this translation here.
And that says we have to get
an operation B 2 pi over 3.
That is located at the original
translation T times
the cotangent of 1/2
of 2 pi over 3.
And that's at 1/2 of the
cotangent of 60 degrees.
And this turns out not to be any
nice neat number like 0 or
1/2, but if you evaluate what
the distance up along the
perpendicular bisector is by
this amount, where you come
out is right in the center
of this triangle.
Trust me.
A little bit of trigonometry
will let you
convince yourself of that.
So if I rotate 120 degrees.
Bring this one to this one,
and then translate over to
here, the way the first one and
the second one are related
is by a 120 degree rotation
about the
center of this triangle.
If I combine the operation A
minus 2 pi over 3, with this
translation, I go down a
distance x of minus this
amount and that puts me in the
middle of the triangle that is
directly below.
And I can move that back up.
And now I have all the
operations of a threefold axis
about this location.
I can do the same thing with the
threefold axis at another
lattice point.
Another thing I could
do is to just
rotate this by 120 degrees.
And by either route, you
find there must be a
threefold axis here.
Notice that these threefold
axes will once again, as
advertised, simply take things
that are at the different
corners of the cell.
For example, this threefold axis
will tell you how this
motif is related to this one
is related to this one.
And so it goes through the other
threefold axes as well.
This threefold axis will tell
you this one is related.
No, I don't want
to draw it in.
So this is P3, a pair of
threefold axes in the centers
of the triangle, and another one
at the corner of the cell.
And now I am going to do the
remaining combination of a
rotation axis with a lattice, so
quickly, and it's going to
take your breath away.
And that is seemingly the
most difficult and
complex one of all.
This would be P6.
Sixfold axis plus a
primitive lattice.
And we know it also has
to be hexagonal.
And that will be called P6.
What we're adding to the lattice
is a sixfold axis.
And now what I'm going to do
as a shortcut is to say a
sixfold axis also contains
all the operations
of a threefold axis.
So I can take P3 and drop it
right on top of P6, and that's
going to give me threefold
axes here.
Sixfold axis not only contains
2 pi over 6 and 2 pi over 3,
it also contains the operation
2 pi over 2.
This is the operation of a
twofold axis, and that says I
have to, in addition to the two
full rotation that sits
here get twofold rotations in
the middle of every one of the
translations T2.
So actually, this is going to
be P2 superimposed on P3.
And that's going to give me
these twofold axis and this
threefold axis.
And the only thing I have to do
is to show you what A 2 pi
over 6 combined with
one of these
translations is going to do.
What is A 2 pi over 6 combined
with this translation?
And it's going to be new
operation B 2 pi over 6, and
it's going to be located at 1/2
of T times the cotangent
of 1/2 of 60 degrees, cotangent
of 30 degrees.
And the cotangent of
30 degrees is 2.
So this is going
to be at 1/2--
no, what do I want to say?
This is 30 degrees.
This is one.
This is two.
Cotangent of 30 degrees is this
over this, and that is--
no that's one.
AUDIENCE: It's 2 pi
[? squared 3. ?]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
OK, that's right.
So actually, what that does is
to say the sixfold axis sits
right up here.
So I don't get any new sixfold
axis rotation of 60 degrees
here, followed by translation
is the same as 60 degrees
about here.
So this is P6, and there is a
lot of pure rotation axes
combined with lattices.
We've got P1, P2,
P3, P4, and P6.
Now, what I will do eventually,
when we're all
done here, the plane groups are
not derived in any book or
set of tables that
I am aware of.
And next time, you will get
some notes that do this in
very slow motion fashion
and give you all
the individual steps.
But the international tables
does give you diagrams of the
resulting plane groups, very
nice carefully done figures
along with the representative
arrangement of motifs that
they generate.
But we're not done yet.
We have not let mirror planes
enter the picture.
And so unless there is
dissension or debate, I'd like
to consider what happens when we
take a mirror plane, and we
can combine that with two
different kinds of lattices, a
primitive rectangular net or
a centered rectangular net,
which is called C. And in order
to do that, we need yet
another combination theorem.
Here are the lattice points,
and let me first derive the
plane group that is called PM.
And what I'll do
is to put the--
let me use a squiggly line here,
not because I'm excited
or nervous about this, but just
to distinguish it from
the edges of the cell.
So here is the operation
sigma.
The pattern that is going to
be displayed by the plane
group is once again just the
pattern produced by a mirror
plane hung at every
lattice point.
But now we need a theorem.
What we have here is the
operation of reflection,
followed by a translation that
is perpendicular to the locus
of the reflection line.
And we will ask what is that?
Again, you get the answer by
just looking at once and for
all, and say, if here is
a first one and it is
right-handed, and I reflect it
to one number to a second one,
number two, which is
left-handed, and then move
that by translation here to get
number three, which stays
left-handed if I move
by translation.
And ask now how was one
related to three.
The chirality is changed.
Reflection is the only thing
available to us, and lo and
behold, if I say there is a new
mirror plane here, that
tells me how this is related
to this, and this one is
related to this one.
And this to this and this to
this, so the answer to this
question is that a reflection
combined with a perpendicular
translation is a new reflection
operation sigma
prime that is located at a
distance removed from the
first by 1/2 of that
perpendicular translation.
And again, it's a plane old
mirror plane just like the
first one, but notice that the
disposition of objects
relative to the mirror plane in
the center of the cell is
quite distinct from the
disposition of objects
relative to the first mirror
plane, so this is a second
mirror plane.
It is an independent mirror
plane from the first.
So that is plane group PM.
If there's symmetry in this
business, you might ask is
there a plane group AM?
The answer is yes in
three dimensions.
There is a space group, PM, and
there's a space group AM.
So there's AM and PM, and there
is symmetry, and all is
well in the universe.
OK, we're making great
progress here.
And we'll be fairly well along
before we have to bring things
to a close.
Let's do the second addition
that's possible
with a mirror plane.
And that is to take a reflection
operation and add
it to the translations that
are present in a centered
rectangular net.
We've already done all the work
for PM, so we can use
that as a starting point.
The pattern of this plane group
is going to look like a
pair of objects related
by reflection.
But now, we'll have an extra
pair hung at the centered
lattice point as well.
And the first thing we can note
is that this mirror plane
is no longer independent
of the first one.
What goes on at this mirror
plane is something that's
related to what happens at the
origin lattice point and
mirror plane, and therefore,
these two mirror planes are
going to do the same thing.
The pattern of this plane group,
we've taken a mirror
plane and added it to a centered
rectangular net.
This is called a C lattice,
standing for centered.
And correspondingly,
the symbol for this
plane group is CM.
We know how this one is
related to this one.
This one related to this one.
And now, we've got something
of a problem.
All of these motifs
are equivalent.
How is this one related
to this one?
Or in more general terms, what
we're asking is suppose I have
a reflection operation sigma,
and I add the translation not
at right angles to it, as I
did here, but place the
translation at an angle
with respect to
the reflection plane.
So what we're going to do is to
take a first motif that's
right-handed, reflect it to
a second one, which is
left-handed.
And then slide it along so that
it sits up in the same
position relative to this
centered lattice point.
So here's number three,
translation leaves it
left-handed.
So I've taken the operation of
reflection combined it with a
translation that has a
perpendicular component plus a
parallel component,
perpendicular and parallel
meaning the orientation of these
two components of the
translation relative to the
reflection operation.
Anybody want to hazard a guess
on how that first one is
related to the third one?
Number one is right-handed.
Number two is left-handed,
so it's got to
be reflection, right?
If I put a reflection plane in
here, this one ought to be
tilted like this.
That's not going
to do the job.
Anybody got any idea?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What is that,
T, T1 [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: OK.
T parallel plus T perpendicular
means it's a
component of this translation.
This is T. This has a part T
perpendicular, and it has a
part T parallel relative to
the initial mirror plane.
My friends, we have just
stumbled headlong over a new
type of symmetry operation,
which we have discovered upon
making this combination
of mirror plane
with a centered lattice.
And it's come up to smack us
rudely in the face even though
we may not have been
clever enough to
think of it in advance.
This is a new type of operation,
and it is an
operation that cannot be reduced
to one of the simple
operations that we've
defined so far.
You've got to take two steps
to get from number one to
number three.
The way you can do it is to
reflect along a locus that is
one half of the way along the
perpendicular part of the
translation, exactly the same
location as we found the
symmetry plane positioned when
the translation was normal to
the first mirror plane.
But yet we can't put the
object down yet in the
position that would be produced
by translation,
because our translation is
inclined to the mirror plane.
So I've got to take
a second step.
Reflect.
Don't yet put it down yet.
Before you put it down, slide
it up parallel to the mirror
plane by an amount that's
equal to the part of the
translation that is parallel
to the mirror plane.
So to summarize this before
all these words get too
confusing, I'm saying that a
reflection operation combined
with a general translation
that has a perpendicular
component in the parallel
component relative to the
locus of reflection is going to
be a new operation, which
I'll write as sigma tau,
a reflection part and a
translation tau that is parallel
to the mirror plane,
and tau is equal to the part
of the translation that is
parallel to the mirror plane.
Astounding.
This is a two-step operation
that cannot be described in
terms simpler than saying
do two steps to do it.
And we'll see as we go along,
particularly into a
three-dimensional space, that
there are other two-step
operations as well.
Now you're all familiar with a
pattern like this, because in
very short order when New
England's winter descends upon
us, as you go slogging along
from your room into the
Institute, your footprints will
make a pattern like that
in the snow.
Exactly what we've got here.
Reflect across and slide.
Reflect across and slide,
and this is the
glide component tau.
And this is an operation that
is called a glide plane.
And it's a new type of
symmetry operation.
It can only exist in a
pattern, which has
translational periodicity.
And if we were not clever enough
to invent it, we would
see it as soon as we combined a
mirror plane with a lattice
that was non-primitive and had
a translation parallel to it.
So it's a very, very
descriptive
name, the glide plane.
Reflect and glide, reflect and
glide, reflect and glide.
It sounds like something you'd
be doing in the Arthur Murray
dance studio, very melodious.
Reflect and glide, reflect
and glide.
It's a nice operation.
All right, so what has happened
then when we add a
mirror plane to a centered
rectangular net is that we get
a new operation coming in,
something completely new.
We've got a symbol to represent
an individual
operation, sigma the symbol
for reflection with a
subscript tau.
And the pattern we've already
drawn, but let's do it again
in a tidy fashion.
Exactly as advertised, the pair
of objects related by
reflection hung at every
lattice point of-- holy
mackerel, look at this.
That would give you
the willies.
That's the nature
of the motif.
Get that out of there.
Mirror planes going through
the lattice points.
Glide planes halfway
in between.
The mirror lines and the glide
planes tell us how things on
the right side, for example,
of the lattice point are
related to the motif of opposite
chirality on the
left-hand side of the centered
lattice point.
And this is a plane group
that is called CM.
AUDIENCE: Question.
PROFESSOR: Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: How can we just define
a new operation that's
a two-step.
Seems like we could do this
forever, define two steps of
any new operation, like you
said, with two steps.
PROFESSOR: That's
a good question.
We found this, because we
tripped headlong over it.
And we say OK, there it is.
We've got to deal with it.
But you're right.
How do you know that rotating
once reflecting, and then
turning end over end three times
is not a new operation
that cannot be decomposed, is
the word that's used for it,
into something simpler?
The answer is you've
got to try it.
If they're there, when we make
these combinations of a
symmetry operation, and now the
symmetry operation can be
a two-step symmetry operation,
now that we've discovered
that, combine that with lattice
and with rotation and
with reflection, and ask what
is the relation between the
motif at the beginning and
the motif at the end.
If you can't describe it any
more simply other than a hop,
skip and jump, you've got to
introduce the hop, skip, and
jump as an element that
goes into the
derivation of these groups.
Now before you get concerned and
fill out an add/drop card,
I have to reassure you that
there are a couple of two-step
operations that we have yet to
discover, but there are no
three-step operations
that are necessary.
Whew.
Feel better now, don't you?
AUDIENCE: I was just going to
say it's kind of arbitrary,
because you have a and b, you're
just applying the third
[INAUDIBLE]
T sub a and b, [INAUDIBLE]
trivial multiplication tables.
PROFESSOR: Well, actually,
this is
something that is distinct.
I mean here is the group, and
you cannot describe the
relation between everything that
is in this pattern, which
was obtained simply by taking
the operation of reflection--
we know how to peacefully
coexist with that--
and placing that pair of objects
at lattice point of a
centered rectangular net.
So that's nothing
really freaky.
I mean it's a straightforward
addition, but if it's a group,
you have to know when you
combine all the operations
pairwise that it'd be able to
show that these operations are
members of a group.
And the answer in terms of the
language of group theory, if
you combine a reflection with
a translation that has a
component that is parallel to
the reflection plane, then
there is a new operation that
comes up that has to be in the
group multiplication table,
and the operation has a
reflection part and a
translation part.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: How do we go from the
lower left to the upper
right in one operation?
PROFESSOR: The lower left
to the upper right.
AUDIENCE: No, the upper
right diagonally.
Across the diagonal, the upper
right corner of the square.
PROFESSOR: Upper right here?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
And the left-handed
guide below that.
PROFESSOR: The left-handed
guide below.
AUDIENCE: No.
Down there.
PROFESSOR: Where
is down there?
AUDIENCE: The lowest
edge of the--
PROFESSOR: Down here?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK.
From this one to this one?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK.
What I can say is--
may sound like I'm slipping
off the hook too easily--
we said that we really only want
to consider operations
that terminate within the cell,
and the way I get from
here to here is to reflect and
then translate up by the
diagonal translation.
So that's something that
lies outside the cell.
So I can always knock off
an integral number of
translations or add on
translations to any mapping
transformation, modulo T. OK?
AUDIENCE: But surely, if you've
done, one operation
then it's [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: From here to here?
No, not necessarily.
If I give you a very simple
pattern and plane group P1,
and you ask how do I get from
this one here to this one that
sits up here?
If it's outside the cell, I've
got to go translation that's
outside the cell.
But it's not any new
translation or
any new sort of operation.
This is sort of in the
same category.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You can make
a glide plane in the
center of the cell.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, OK.
Thank you.
There is a glide operation that
goes from here to here
and then translates up by
one full translation.
But a glide operation that
is an integral number of
translations says that
you're dealing with--
there's another object that is
removed by a translation that
is the same thing.
So it is first and that simpler
one that would be
inside of the cell and would
be only the unique sort of
translation you need
to consider.
Thank you.
That's a good question.
That was a good answer
to his question.
In fact, anybody want
to take over?
I didn't do well on that one.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I was curious.
Does the glide plane exist maybe
in this case because
we're not using a
primitive cell?
If you were to consider this
[INAUDIBLE] as hexagonal?
PROFESSOR: OK, let me answer
that question by saying that
that's our first encounter
with it.
But now, that it exists, that
is a symmetry element, which
we should consider adding to
lattices in addition to pure
reflection.
So let me proceed now to do
another plane group since we
had discovered the operation
of glide.
And I will take a primitive
rectangular lattice, and I
will now add to the lattice
point, not a mirror plane, but
a glide plane.
OK.
The pattern is going to look
like the pattern of glide,
have things left and right
on either side
of the glide plane.
The same thing here.
And there is the pattern.
This is a pattern that's
called PG.
And what I have to ask is what
is the guide operation sigma
tau combined with, let's say
this translation T1.
And the answer is that if I
reproduce number one to number
two of opposite chirality by the
glide operation sigma tau
and then follow that by T1 the
first and the third will be
related by a new glide operation
sigma tau prime
that's located at half
perpendicular part of the
translation away
from the first.
And that really is a
generalization of this
relation here.
If we make the pure reflection
operation a glide operation,
combine it with a translation
that is perpendicular to it,
it turns out that the net
result is a new glide
operation, sigma tau prime.
The two taus are equal, and this
occurs at one half of the
translation T perpendicular
removed from the first.
And the complete generalization
would be to say
if I have a translation that
has a parallel part and a
perpendicular part relative to
the glide plane, what I will
get is a new glide operation
sigma prime that's located at
1/2 of the perpendicular part
of the translation from the
first, and it will pick up a
glide component that's equal
to the original tau plus the
part of the translation that's
parallel to the glide plane.
So this now is this theorem
involving translation and
reflection type operations
in its most general form.
OK.
So this is a new group called
CM, and it consists of pairs
of objects.
Sorry, we did that earlier.
This is PG, pairs of objects
related by a glide plane, hung
at every lattice point of the
primitive rectangular lattice.
Is there a CG?
Actually, there is not, and let
me show you why, and then
I think we're just about
quitting time.
If there is a centered lattice,
and I hang a glide
plane at the lattice points,
we'll have glide planes in the
locations of PG, the pattern
will look like objects
repeated by glide.
At this lattice point, and now
we're going to have another
object hung at the centered
lattice point, and it's going
to be in positions like this.
Now, you can see just by looking
at the pattern that
there is going to be--
whoops, what did I do here?
I want to move this one up to
here, and I want to move this
one up to here.
This one should be
in this location.
If I look at that pattern, what
I've done is to create
halfway along the--
quarter of the way along
the translation a
pure reflection operation.
And I can find that using
my general theorem.
I have a glide operation,
sigma tau.
I combine with that the centered
translation, which is
1/2 of T1 plus 1/2 of T2.
I've taken 1/2 of T1 plus 1/2
of T2, that's the centering
translation, combined
that with sigma tau.
I'll deftly jump to the side, so
the people against the wall
can see it.
I've taken a glide operation,
combined it with this
translation.
This should be a new reflection
type of operation
that will be located at 1/2 of
the perpendicular part of the
translation, and that's
at 1/2 of 1/2 of T1.
And it will have a glide
component tau prime, which is
the original tau, which
was 1/2 of T2.
And to that we add the
parallel part of the
translation, and that
is 1/2 of T2.
So this is rewritten in slightly
different form, is
simply a new glide plane sigma
prime, which has a glide
component equal to the entire
translation T2 at
1/4 quarter of T1.
And this is the same as a
mirror plane at 1/4 T1.
And this, if we compare
it with CM, is
exactly the same thing.
Identical to CM with an origin
shift of 1/4 T1.
So there is no CG in what
we picked up in terms of
rectangular nets and symmetry
planes is PM, PG, and CN.
So there are three groups
involving orthogonal nets in a
single symmetry plane.
That is a good place
to wrap things up.
And we'll next turn very, very
quickly equipped with a set of
notes, which summarizes the
result, to what happens when
we take two MM and put it into
a rectangular net, and take
two MM and put it into a
centered rectangular net.
And then things get interesting,
because we've got
two planes.
We can make a both
mirror planes.
We can make them both glides, or
make one a mirror plane and
one a glide plane.
So there are three possibilities
with the
addition of two MM to the net.
More than enough for one day.
It's Thursday.
Take the rest of the
week and weekend
off by doing no symmetry.
There's no assignment,
and we'll have at
it again next Tuesday.